caleb smith only one start and three
innings of work with miami all year at
philadelphia july 25th when he walked
six batters in three innings he's been
trying to play catch-up all year long
the mariners lead off man in scoring
position for their number three hitter
lewis
nice change up right there and he gets
his first strikeout so one on two away
the pitch and seeger strikes out
swinging and the side is retired so
smith strikes out two mariners starting
pitcher 29 euro left-hander you say
kikuchi in his second season with
seattle after coming over from japan
velocity has picked way up this year and
so has his strikeout rate one on and one
away that'll bring up first baseman
christian walker rojas takes off and
that's a base hit down the line josh is
on the run
it's way down there in the corner
they're gonna send him home
walker is rounding second and headed for
third and he's in there with a stand-up
rbi triple he's down there at third for
escobar
and warno sends one to deep left field
dylan moore near the warning track he's
got it here comes walker
and it's two-nothing d-backs the rb guy
for eduardo escobar
dammit swings base it right field
calhoun around third up with it irving
he will not have a play gets it back
into the cut-off man and it's
three-nothing d-backs a man deleted
second base two outs the one-two pitch
swing and i miss for strike three and
that will finally retire the side you
say strikes out mathison surrenders with
a one-out walk and the mariners have a
base runner here in the top half of any
number two
strike three call got him look at third
strikeout for caleb smith two outs for
now for phillip irvine he was the
overall 27th pick he hits one skyward to
left field
going over
is the left fielder rojas hundred makes
the catch
it's the diamondbacks three and the
one up one down to the top of the order
dylan moore who reached on an error the
wind-up band the next offering of dylan
mori swings and clobbers this out to
left field absolutely torched and gone
dylan moore touch them all in the desert
his seventh this year he puts the
mariners on the board rydo escobar
delivered a sacrifice fly in the first
inning
escobar hits it the other way phillip
irvine near the line still on the run he
can't get it rojas had to go back to the
bag escobar is in its second and josh is
standing at third looked like irvin had
it in the glove momentarily and then it
bounced out oh one to calhoun and call
fly ball
center field going back lewis
makes a catch both tag
coming in to score as rojas and going to
third base is escobar so cole calhoun
with a run batted in this 23rd is
sacrificed by the second sacrifice fly
for the dive acts tonight they're on top
four to one third baseman wyatt mathison
leading off the bottom of the fourth
inning
got him again number two for usaid
kikuchi both times striking out matheson
one out for the diamondbacks
here's the pitch hung on fly ball into
right field toward the line on the run
phillip irving is there and makes the
catch and that will end the inning we go
to the top of the fifth from chase field
in downtown phoenix americas have a base
runner here in the top half of the fifth
they haven't had many
folks this one behind the back at second
ahmed going out there
and he's got it in front of le castro
irving back to the bag at second out
number two here's dylan moore the
leadoff man who launched a long home run
off caleb smith in the third the next
off on the way swinging a ground ball to
shore it up with the ball is ahmed he'll
go to second base for the force on irvin
and that will retire the side young has
had two scoreless endings with only a
walk
shot to center lacaster on the run he's
got this one carted ball that time by
lewis but out number two here in the six
two up two down
there's a high fly ball
in her deep right center lecaster on the
run out there and front of the pool
makes the catch on the warning track
and that will end the ending well
alex didn't really fool anybody bad any
but he got three outs on lock fly balls
kikuchi has settled down nicely he's
retired six in a row and nine of the
last 10 batters he's faced here comes
the payoff
swing and a miss strike three good
fastball low and end fourth strike out
of the night for the lefty faces clean
two outs
you stays one two swing and a miss
strike three boy that is a nasty pitch
blowing in at 93 miles an hour fifth
strikeout tonight for you say kikuchi
who's retired the last week in a row
mariners have a runner in scoring
position the pitch
swinging this is clocked out towards the
gap in right center field drops down for
a base hit calhoun takes it on a bounce
evan white quickly pedals around the
back at third he comes home and he
scores standing it's 4-2 arizona
ground ball down to third mathison goes
to second for one and then on to first
and then any double play
nicely turned a backhanded stab at third
on escobar then on to first five four
three double play ends the ending one
run on two hits so quickly two outs with
their second baseman ty france
here's a swing and a high fly ball deep
left field going back looking up rojas
and that one is gone goodbye baseball
first homer is a mariner and we got a
4-3 ball game well here we go to the top
half of the ninth inning baron is
trailing the diamondbacks four to three
two down now for the catcher luis
terrence
one hopper to nick ahmed spins and
throws ball game
they hang on to win this ball game 4-3
over the seattle mariners tonight